After the big ideas thing,
a act came into my classes and tape maps
of meaning and made 1330 minutes,
uh,
TV shows out of them.
And that was pretty interesting.
And they were broadcast and kind of
evanescent because at that point they
weren't put on the web.
So they're broadcast,
they pretty much disappear.
Right.
And um,
so,
so fine.
So,
and I got some degree of,
what would you say I got?
I was exposed,
my ideas were exposed to a large number
of people,
tens of thousands of people as a
consequence of that.
And that seemed to go pretty well.
And so then youtube came along and I
thought,
well,
I don't know what this is,
this youtube thing,
you know,
the comments section makes you like,
what would you say wary about being
human?
I would say generally speaking,
and you know,
there was a lot of,
well there were a lot of things that it
would be easy to be contemptuous of on
Youtube,
like the canonical cute cat videos.
But I'm actually not so contemptuous of
that or the interesting animal videos
because I think they actually speak to a
part of people that's actually quite
good.
We like cats,
we like dogs,
we think animals are kind of cool.
And you know,
we take a break and look at,
look at something that's pleasant and
cute and maybe that's not so bad.
It's not serious,
but it's certainly not malevolent.
And that's something.
So I thought,
okay,
well I'll find these old videos I did
for Tvo and I'll put them up on youtube
and maybe I'll just take my classes.
And so I set up because I have this
theory that if it's worth doing,
it's worth doing badly.
Which you know,
it's true,
but it's also true that if it's worth
doing,
it's worth doing well.
You just need to know when to apply
those two principles.
And if you're loath to do something and
procrastinating,
then sometimes it's better to do it
badly.
And I thought,
well I can't get a whole production
studio up and running and cause I just
don't have the time.
I'll get an IPAD and learn to use it.
And get an level ear mic and just set
the thing up or maybe have a student
film it.
And so I did that for a couple of years
for my personality class in this maps of
meaning class,
which is the class where I outlined this
sorts of ideas that I just described to
you.
And,
uh,
last April I noticed that I'd had a
million views and about 15,000
subscribers,
you know,
and I thought,
Huh,
million views,
hey,
that's an actually a lot of views.
It's like if I,
I've never write a scientific paper
that's been read a million times,
no one has,
that just never happens.
Right.
That's happened zero times.
If it,
if you have a paper that's cited,
you know,
someone else refers to it and one of
their scientific papers a hundred times,
it's like,
that's a home run and a thousand times
is a miracle.
So,
and then if you write a book,
you know,
there's,
I think 1.2 million books published last
year,
something like that.
And I think 500 of them sold more than a
hundred thousand copies.
So that's a sea of books,
right?
It's,
it's an ocean of books and all of them
fail really.
So,
so many of them fail that you might as
well never write a book because the
probability that it will fail is like
99.99%.
And that would be very depressing if it
wasn't the case that that's the case for
anything creative you ever do.
So it's just baseline probability.
But I thought,
well,
if I wrote a book and it sold a million
copies,
man,
I'd be out dancing in the street.
Uh,
probably not.
But you know,
you get the idea.
So what does it mean to have a million
youtube views?
Well,
who the hell knows?
Right?
I mean,
we don't have metrics for that.
We don't know what sort of influence
that's having.
We don't know anything about that.
We don't know whether we should take it
seriously or,
or if it's or who you're talking to or
anything.
But I thought,
well,
still it's a million then that's a lot.
And I thought,
well,
maybe this is,
this is more serious thing than I
initially envisioned.
And then I really thought about it and I
thought,
okay,
oh,
I get it.
Here's a hypothesis.
You know,
back in the medieval times and before if
you wanted to book someone had to copy
it by hand.
And so there weren't any books and they
were very expensive.
And so,
and then Gutenberg came along and
invented the movable type press and it
was like poof.
Books were inexpensive and everybody
could have them and not like was that
was a major revolution,
right?
It within 400 years,
almost everyone in the western world and
then very rapidly,
almost everyone in the entire world was
literate.
He could read silently even,
which was something that before that was
reserved for a very small number of
people because most people read out loud
when they read it all.
So that was a massive revolution.
And then I thought,
wait a minute,
maybe youtube is a Gutenberg revolution
because it allows the spoken word to
have the same reach and longevity as a
book
for the first time in human history,
spontaneous speeches can reach an
infinite audience for eye for an
unspecified duration of time.
Well,
that's a whole new thing.
That's a,
that's an entirely new thing.
And maybe it's easier for people to
listen than it is for them to read.
You know?
I mean,
I'd rather read than listen cause I can
read way faster than I can listen.
But people will listen to a youtube
video at twice the normal speed,
sometimes more.
So you can circumvent that.
And then also with a youtube video,
if you convert it into a podcast,
let's say,
which I'll get to to a moment,
you all of a sudden have way more time
than you used to have because you can
listen to a podcast while you're doing
other things.
So you can do mundane,
the mundane things that you have to do
from day to day,
like commute and so on.
But you can listen to a podcast.
And I've found that my,
my young students are now listening to
podcasts instead of music.
And that's really something,
you know,
because music of course,
it's been an unbelievably dynamic
cultural force for maybe the,
the primary artistic cultural force for
what maybe maybe since the 1950s
anyways.
And that's being supplanted to some
degree by podcasts.
And that's really something.
And then it also turns out that people
have an appetite for long,
detailed podcasts that are deep and
informative.
It's like,
who the hell would've guessed that?
Like no one.
It's it.
It just sorta came out of nowhere.
And so I thought,
well,
maybe this is worth taking seriously.